imagine a virtual reality experience
where when you go into this vet reality
world everything looks like it's real
and you can navigate around it and begin
to do extraordinary things in this high
fidelity world at home you will have
yourself 3d scanned down to the
millimeter I then enter into a virtual
world and I have an AI there that is my
shopping adviser it says Peter what
you're looking for and all of a sudden
in this virtual world everything I see
is in my size in the colors I want
recommended by this AI and I can say you
know I'd love to see a fashion show on a
runway our avatars of me wearing all
these different outfits walking by and I
can say I want I want to see that one in
that one and all of a sudden I'm looking
in a virtual mirror and I'm wearing that
outfit and I can look around see what it
looks like and I go this is it
I want that boom it's produced
manufactured to my exact size probably
using 3d printing capabilities or
robotic capabilities that afternoon in
the local Factory and deliver it the
next morning and it fits perfectly so
that's the future of the virtual retail
store if you would and why I think
virtual reality is going to do
effectively a hundredfold improvement
over what the Amazon experience is today
you